however given that the wand was well
broken it backfired on that card instead
the faulty wand sent him flying into a
pile of rubble and subsequently caused
him to lose all of his memories complete
Amnesia he was no longer the brave troll
conqueror and dragon tamer in fact he
didn't know who he was Lockhart is later
saved by forks and brought to
mcgonagall's office at which point it
became apparent to staff and students
alike that Lockhart had completely lost
his marbles with Dumbledore instructing
Ron to take him to the hospital Wing
after careful inspection it was decided
that Lockhart wouldn't be able to
operate in society in the state that he
was in and he was subsequently sent to
the jainus Thicke ward in Saint mungo's
Hospital for Magical maladies a war
dedicated to those suffering from
permanent spell damage during Christmas
in 1995 Harry Ron Hermione and Ginny saw
Lockhart in the jainus sticky Ward and
despite the total loss of his memory he
seemed just as Lockhart as ever offering
a